non pas qu midi atelier musique avec
elisa qui monte chaque été l'association
pour le lien l'entr'aide et le droit à
la différence
organise des séjours au bord de la mer
dans le sud de la france pour les grands
ou dans le haut doubs pour les plus
jeunes
mais cette année les protocoles
sanitaires est en trés lourd seul
l'accueil à la journée a proposé un
manque à gagner pour la structure et une
croix de plus dans la colonne effet du
clipping pour équilibrer notre budget on
doit trouver chaque année à peu près
trente mille euros
donc on fait de nombreuses
manifestations on s'entoure de pas mal
de partenaires de chorales orchestres
universitaires etc
donc c'est tous des événements qui était
programmé depuis le mois de février
jusque jusqu'au début juillet qui ont
été annulés une situation vécue par 91%
des associations selon l' enquête menée
par le mouvement associatif
la led qui compte une soixantaine
d'adhérents parents d'enfants handicapés
pour la plupart a rapidement constitué
des dossiers dette financière pour
poursuivre son activité
caisse d'allocations familiales état et
département ont déjà apporté leur
soutien j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une
bonne organisation entre eux pour ne pas
nous laisser tomber
ils ont travaillé ensemble pour trouver
des solutions mais pour beaucoup
d'associations l'incertitude plane sur
le budget 2020 elles ne sont que 16 % à
affirmer qu'elles seront dans les clous
ou presque en fin d'année 26% sont
incapables de répondre des données
chiffrées pour cibler les priorités
l'objectif de l'enquète c'était pouvoir
nous en tant que mouvement associatif
aller auprès des pouvoirs publics et
leur dire attention à l'erc
certains secteurs d'activité plus que
d'autres les associations on pense
souvent aux associations employeuses
mais pensez aussi à toutes les
associations qui n'ont pas de salarié
les associations ont besoin du soutien
des pouvoirs publics mais aussi de la
mobilisation des bénévoles
et puis du soutien des citoyens tu vas
regarde regarde ses oreilles sont
pointus là à la ferme aux lamas pas de
salarié pas dead
la perte financière engendrée par plus
de trois mois de fermeture ne sera pas
rattrapable mais la crise sanitaire n'a
pas tout balayer en particulier pour la
cinquantaine de bénévoles qui se
relaient pour accueillir le public
je pense que pour eux ça a été aussi
difficile de parvenir à la ferme parce
qu'ils ont ils ont énormément d'attachés
aussi bien avec les animaux que à
l'intérieur de l'association et puis on
a eu notre premier retour de dan au
groupe d'enfants en situation de
handicap
et là ça a été patricia tu m'a tellement
manqué tout de suite mais il est où
jolie cahill et aux mâles vers le côté
positif ça a été de se rendre compte de
l'impact qu'on avait vraiment le
confinement a changé fragiliser le monde
associatif
la majorité des structures mais sur
septembre pour un retour à la normale
des activités à condition que l'automne
ne soit pas synonyme d'art confinement